hello friends and welcome back to the
show that is in a word
toasty it's only gonna get warmer
because this episode of versus features
a high-flying fatal four-way of fabulous
flick franchises that were somewhat
forgotten by the critics it's resident
and evil taking on tomb raider against
portal combat
battling street fighter what does this
quadrilogy have in
kwamen that's right they all won best
picture
at the oscar no they did not win best
picture but they are all video game
movie franchises
that are rotten on the tomato meter
dismissed by the critics
slighted by movie reviewers punished by
pundits but today
they get their chance at justice
redemption and will definitely also be
made fun of a lot
by uh this guy uh-huh right
i am a fella raised on movies and video
games and so finally
after some 49 episodes at this job i
finally get to sound
intelligent 14 films four franchises and
here's how it all breaks down
in one quarter you have the six resident
evil films
based on the uber successful horror
video game line
star mila yovovich and a horde of
zombies have cultivated
an impressively sized and fiercely loyal
fan base
against them is tomb raider which boasts
two a-list stars who have stepped into
the globe trotting
brave robbing shoes of lara croft facing
off with mortal kombat who's now
three feature films involve a fighting
tournament in which the very fate of
earth is at stake
is that the one with the monsters no
it's a different movie and rounding out
the match
is street fighter who we invited is a
common curtis
okay look the legend of chun li does
have some cool parts and i love van
damme and rau julia
damn street fighter might actually have
a shot today here's how we'll determine
a winner
round one box office round two tomato
meter slash
audience score round three characters
round four best foot forward and then
we'll do a wild card round
provided we don't run out of quarters
and our mom isn't done shopping yet
yes for today we all have the same mom
she's a nice lady who takes us to
newport news
virginia that hotbed of pop culture
known as patrick henry mall
to see movies and play video games at
the tilt arcade
and it was legendary video game
enthusiast patrick henry who said
give me liberty or give me at least a
few more bucks in quarters so i can play
the game where blood goes everywhere
know your history kids let's get it on
come to a little tournament he said be
good for the career he said
right so look at this
round one box office upon leaving said
tilt arcade you'll walk through the food
court and if you can successfully evade
the delicious smells of chick-fil-a free
samples
villa pizza and panda express you're
gonna land at a movie theater
where all four of these franchises had
the opportunity
to cash in on their fan bases big time
street fighter came out of the gate
first
and tried to do it previous video game
flicks like super mario brothers and
double dragon couldn't
make money off of a 35 million dollar
budget
it only made and adjusted for inflation
73 million dollars here in the states
but did manage a worldwide total of 219
million dollars so let's give it a tip
of guile's cap
the star power of van damme and rod
julia's m bison had set a new bar
but then the very next year
jump kicked right over it with a 258
million worldwide run
however mortal kombat annihilation
failed to match that success
barely limping over the 100 million
dollar mark and we'll wait to see
how the new mortal kombat fares in
theaters but don't
worry that's not the last you're gonna
hear about the new one in this fun and
informative
video essay resident evil came out of
the gate strong and has not looked back
as the original
is the lowest grosser in the franchise
but it still made a respectable 164
million dollars worldwide
and resident evil afterlife set the high
mark for the film series
at 345 million dollars meanwhile
angelina jolie's two
tomb raider films average out to 248
million dollars across the earth but
it's alicia vikander's most recent
iteration of miss croft
that tops all of our movies in
competition today raking in a
get this 442 million dollar total haul
that buys a lot of plane tickets while
mortal kombat and street fighter duke it
out for the bronze medal in this round
the gold either goes to tomb raider or
resident evil
is it more impressive to have three
films all dominate the box office
or to have a slate of six flicks that
consistently do solid business making
box office coin is what this round is
all about and although resident evil
has a legion of loyal followers that
have supported it at the cinema since
2002
tomb raider has been able to survive
since 2001
despite a 15-year nap angelina gave up
the title after 2003's the cradle of
life
and it wasn't until 2018 that vicander
breathed life into the new franchise
took the skull and ran with it
the average resident evil movie takes in
248 million dollars worldwide
but only 59 million dollars per flick
here in the united states
tomb raider has a much more balanced
ledger as it generates an average of 123
million dollars domestically
and 318 million dollars worldwide
i have a feeling that resident evil is
going to be competitive in each and
every round in today's matchup
but for round number one the winner is
tomb raider
thank you angelina kudos alicia and hats
off to the director of the 2018 version
who just happens to have the greatest
name of all time
roar uthog it just does not get any
better than that
how do you even tell a kid named roar
that they're grounded you can't
roar doesn't have to make his bed if
roar wants more allowance roar gets it
and his movie franchise roared into the
lead one to nothing
to nothing to nothing
round two tomato meter slash audience
scores
and now these 14 movies realize why we
match them up together in the first
place
uh the critics don't necessarily love
all of them
some have managed uh modicum of respect
amongst the film reviewing profession
but these are four rotten movie
franchises so let's sugarcoat it by
going to the audience score side of
things first
never give up hope there you go resident
evil the six films of that series stand
the tallest tier averaging an
oh so close to fresh 55
rotten but hot on its heels are both
tomb raider and mortal kombat
registering at respect to 49 and 41
although at the time of this sentence
being typed 2021's mk
is sitting at a very healthy audience
metric of 87
okay so we're all feeling pretty good
none of these franchises are all that
stinky if the audience has it
oh god i forgot street fighter me on tv
i'm on tv
leave it let's take a look oh
it's not great 19 average
which means street fighter is the
breadwinner of the franchise at 20
percent
tyson you're on the air
as we keep an eye on the brand new
mortal kombat the original sets the high
audience score for its series at 57
2018's tomb raider scores sammy hagar's
nemesis of 55
but only resident evil can brag about
having movies
make it into fresh audience score
territory the original leads the way at
67 percent
and apocalypse makes the grade with a d
minus 60
just like my college career but enough
with all of this beating around the bush
we brought you all here
because you're rotten movies so let's
get the band-aid ripped off
none i repeat none of these 14 movies
we're talking about
are fresh even the new mortal kombat is
currently at 55
that number could still change but
history doesn't indicate that it's a
promising prognosis
mortal kombat annihilation is a horrible
horrible movie and i'm honestly
surprised it made it all the way
up to two percent on the tomato meter
hey congrats you're only three points
below
street fighter the legend of chun li and
street fighter from 94
is at a 10 which makes it look like
citizen kane
wow some of these movies are really
really bad
damn you barbecued his ass
it's a shame because a movie like 1995's
mortal kombat is so good
and it at least has a saving face 48
percent tomato meter score currently
it's only looking up at tomb raider the
legend of roruthog
resident evil has stayed consistently
rotten for its entire run
but never dipping below 20 or getting
beyond 40 percent
the final chapter but was it though
leads the way with 37
apocalypse one of the fresh movies on
the audience side of things
is actually the lowest rated on the
tomato meter at 20 percent
once again it appears tomb raider and
resident evil are battling at a
different cruising altitude
mortal kombat can at least fly and
street fighter is already on the bus to
the next round
tomb raider narrowly edges out resident
evil in terms of tomato meter average
winning 32 percent to 28 ah
but here comes mila as the audience
score average for resident evil
tops all of our other franchises and
that is what's gonna just get it over
the finish line
to win round two filmmakers whose movies
end up rotten
always claim that their art is for the
fans not the critics but in the case of
video game adaptations
you tend to believe it the games set
very strict parameters in which to tell
a story and the more popular the game
the less wiggle room in the sandbox
resident evil knows this lesson as well
as any
to date the video games have sold a
combined 107 million
copies since 1996. that's the best in
our game here
winning the silver medal you guessed it
tomb raider which came out the very same
year
and has since moved 81 million units
resident evil ties things up in this
round two win and mortal kombat and
street fighter
are still looking for their first point
i see you mother round three
characters and here's where those
classic fighting games who spawn movies
of
questionable quality have a good shot
it's a must-have round for both mortal
kombat and street fighter
and look say we won about street fighter
or just look at the tomato meter scores
again
but they have super rad characters
because they were plucked
directly out of one of the great video
games of all time
unfortunately most of the character
performances aren't all that memorable
save one
[Music]
no no no not you jcvd you were
passable as guile but i still maintain
vega would have been a better role for
you
i'm of course talking about ral julia as
m
bison and then i will immediately plea
for you all to hear me out
okay so on my initial watch of the flick
back when it came out
i didn't get it at all from the country
the movie was a huge disappointment and
i wasn't sure why raul
would want to be that character at all
however i decided to put myself through
watching it again
recently and through a satirical lens
similar to 1987's robocop
m bison is by far the best part of that
movie why
because he's having fun bisonopoulos
are you kidding me rau julia leaned into
the absurdist humor
and while that may not have satiated a
kid fresh out of the arcade's desire for
high-flying martial arts combat
as an adult comedian it got me through
the re-watch
bison would sadly be ral julia's last
screen appearance
and he agreed to do it why because he
thought it would cement his legacy as
one of the best actors of his generation
which he is
no it's because his kids loved the video
game
and knowing that he was sick facing
impossible fear and pain
he took the role to give his kids one
last image of their father
plus rebel was a master of comedy go
back and watch the two adams family
movies from the 90s
they are note perfect the day bison
graced your village
was the most important day of your life
but i digress and i'm sorry that i
actually wanted to talk about a few
films that are actually fresh in the
tomato meter for a change
all right back to stinksville on the
subject of tomb raider it's tough to
compete with films that feature a gaggle
of beloved heroes
like your fighters or your combats but
lara croft
as performed by either award-winning
actress does all
she can as a swashbuckling lead that can
do it all dazzle with stunts deliver
clunky dialogue like a pro and put butts
in seats
and despite an interesting but odd turn
with angelina jolie's real daddy john
voigt
or menacing walton goggins in 2018 it's
a far cliff to fall between
lara and anyone else in those films a
similar fate dooms resident evil
miliovich's alice cemented her legacy as
a true action star
and the staying power of a franchise
that has produced six profitable films
since 2002
reinforces that claim over the course of
the run notable performances from
michelle rodriguez
mike epps ali larter ian glenn and many
more
have been turned in but no one walking
into a resident evil movie has room for
debate over who to root for
just like the tomb raider flicks and
while that's not a bad thing
in the competitive world of video games
the setting is so right to get
fans arguing over who their favorite is
particularly
with your fighting games mortal kombat
isn't on the board
yet in part because the simplistic
premise doesn't scream for multiple big
screen adaptations
but in a round devoted to characters
here comes liu kang
sonia blade johnny cage and the rest of
the gang and that's just the folks that
that first movie
wanted you to root for but who cares
what they want i'm there to cheer on my
guy
sub-zero and to be dazzled by his
arch-enemy scorpion
see it's like i don't care what happens
in the gi joe movies but when snake eyes
and storm shadow fight
i need a large popcorn and everyone else
to shut the hell up
in the newest iteration lewis tan does a
magnificent job as cole
anchoring the action and lending a
humanity to the
nuttiness happening on screen the
original also utilized humor in a less
spoofy way than street fighter to win us
over
cage blade and kang all knew the
ludicrous nature of this tournament
and the incredibly daunting odds they
face sealing the deal for mortal kombat
in this round
is christopher lambert's batty rendition
of raiden
he is having a blast similar to rau
julia and street fighter
but the cast around lamb bear is also
enjoying the ride and giving fans of the
video game a reward for their loyalty
the characters live up to the hype
mortal kombat wins the round and makes
it a three-way tie at the top
the fate of billions will depend upon
you
sorry round four best foot forward
in the case of mortal kombat and street
fighter this is gonna be literally the
case
uh they kick people in the face like a
lot overall this round will sort out the
best movie from each franchise
and pit them against one another to see
who has bragging rights to be the
best of the best where were we
you were losing given all the insanity
taking place in the resident evil world
it's admirable when they have characters
make multiple appearances throughout the
franchise
and you know actually make a cohesive
story above all the others
this is a film series that can be
accused of feeling like one long movie
but standing out from the rest of the
pack for this guy is resident evil
apocalypse it's curiously the lowest of
the film set on the tomato
meter but is fresh with the fans in no
small part
because the action is simply bonkers
alice
literally drives a motorcycle through a
church window
somehow doesn't get struck by holy
lightning in the process and sets the
bar for anyone going to worship
heretofore mila yovovich did most of her
own stunts and it pays off in sequences
like when she's hurtly running through a
building and doing some incredible
acrobatics along the way
the film is further buoyed by strong
supporting roles from the aforementioned
epps
glenn sienna gilroy and jared harris as
dr
charles ashford it's a tough lot to pick
a favorite from because i also love the
bathroom fight from afterlife
and the winged demon creatures from the
final chapter but alas
apocalypse is my resident evil
representative here
and it will go up against street fighter
and probably not break a sweat street
fighter just isn't that good
like at all m bison makes it worse
sticking around but more than anything
it makes me
lament that we had to waste both a great
franchise opportunity
and van damme in his prime on this 10
rotten misfire
keep in mind in 1994 jean-claude was
coming off of hard target and nowhere to
run and was aiming to be
the next great action star then this
happened
i will say he recovered quickly with
time cop which is still cool
but street fighter remains a gigantic
eyesore during an otherwise impressive
run
you'll have to do better than that okay
not so with mortal kombat
and i'm gonna champion the original here
i did like the new one as well but i
don't want to have any recency bias so
i'm sticking with the classic
yes i said it classic 1995 version
for all time iconic moments the resident
evil franchise easily wins
in terms of sheer volume but pound for
pound i'd put this combat up there with
any one video game flick
from the insidious disguising of shang
tsung to kick things off
togoro crushing an entire thanksgiving
meal by himself
to a worthy final clash between sung and
liu kang
this movie has it all but the most
chill-inducing moment for me
is still the introduction of sub-zero
and scorpion
it led the trailer blew us away in the
theater
and you've probably used that gif a few
dozen times
these fellas are in some weird green
room on a boat and they emerge from the
door
looking like the most badass
intimidating twinsies
of all time poor kano and especially
non-video game character art we
get the shaft a bit but this entire
flick feels like one big march madness
single elimination sports tournament and
that's what keeps us invested from start
to finish
well that and the music that theme will
even make the laziest of comedians get
out of bed and work out
or do three push-ups and go back to bed
[Music]
alicia vikander's tomb raider is my pick
out of that franchise here
and that film isn't short on excitement
and does not waste a lot of time before
we lock into a fast-paced trek across
the world
you got your bike chases you got
motorcycle combat and various weapon
battles become par for the course
but my highlight was the intensity of
the river waterfall scene
now look we've all seen something like
this countless times before
the hero of the story has to make a
daring escape just before the racing
waters toss them over a cliff
but here let's throw in a crashed
airplane and vikander is more than
capable in making
us believe she's physically up to the
task of surviving such a stunt
her facing the ultimate fortune hunting
baddie in walton goggins works well
and reconnecting with her father also
delivers an emotional gut
punch but ultimately none of these other
franchise bests can equal the staying
power
the highlights or the fun of the
original mortal kombat
the newest version sometimes feels like
it's trying to match its predecessor's
levity
but then also gets super serious and
it's kind of forcing that
end of the world intensity resident evil
apocalypse and the new tomb raider helps
solidify those titles as worthy video
game franchises for sure
but it's 1995's mortal kombat that
breathed real life into this entire
genre
and it unlocked the potential for all
other gaming flicks to follow
mortal kombat wins the round and goes up
two
to one to one to zero
i smell something
[ __ ]
and now it's time for our wild card
round origin of the species
yep we're gonna pull a charles darwin
and head to our version of the galapagos
islands
no no we're not going to be charting
evolution so much as we'll be taking a
gander at where it all began
the video games themselves i know i know
it's a show about movies but come on how
many times do i get to gush about four
video game franchises that have molded
me
into the semi-capable adult that i am
the question here is quite simple
which video game series stands the
tallest
finally street fighter has a shot here
largely on the strength of street
fighter 2
turbo fighting both in the arcade and on
platforms like super nintendo
this game permanently set the template
for all fighting games to follow
it wasn't the first but it might have
been the best diverse settings
all over the world and a bevy of unique
characters such as ryu
ken chun lee dalseem and of course m
bison himself
made for tremendous replay value ryu was
my guy
but as long as i could avoid my
brother's e honda 100 hand slap
i was okay with blanca just don't leave
him plugged in for too long
because it's not going to end well we
were indeed spoiled in the early to mid
90s with one-on-one battles and video
games but if street fighter 2 ushered in
a new era
it was mortal kombat that created a
seismic shift
the digitized look and smooth gameplay
of mortal kombat ran
after previous games like pit fighter
walked and we can't bring up what it was
like to experience mortal kombat
without mentioning the red stuff blood
was everywhere and we had never seen it
before i mean in video games
yeah it's fun to learn the moves
eventually like the sub-zero freeze
stuff but at the beginning
it was just about punching as many times
with luke gang as possible
to see the maximum amount of kool-aid
coming out of your opponent's nose
parents freaked out articles were
written the news covered it ad nauseum
and ultimately
mortal kombat elevated the realistic
look of video games
into a new realm of all the games in
competition here
none had an immediate impact comparable
to what mortal kombat did and the sales
prove it
street fighter has moved a total of 45
million games
since 1987 mortal kombat has sold 54
million copies
since 1992 which by my math means that
673 million spines have been ripped out
of bodies
finish him flawless victory
tomb raider and resident evil came along
in the same year and just because i
would eventually pass my driver's ed
test in 1996
didn't mean i was done with video games
tomb raider was the closest thing we had
in the 90s to a new indiana jones movie
sorry young indy i was more of a briscoe
county junior kid
and the in-depth storytelling throughout
the series has proven to be the perfect
baton handoff to the movies
lara croft was a revolutionary character
not just as a strong female lead but as
someone who could maneuver around and
interact in 3d worlds in a brand new way
moving 81 million copies over the course
of the franchise is no small feat and
makes it competitive in this round
but here comes resident evil and it
managed to achieve what very few games
have even attempted to do
it's scary as hell silent hill would
also find success in the horror genre
and oculus style headsets have made it
even easier in the modern era to
frighten a gamer with a well-timed jump
scare
but the franchise of resident evil was
an experience unlike any other
gamers like myself would legit be
nervous not just for our own survival
but because we were genuinely terrified
at what could jump out next
there's been great fighting games before
and since mortal kombat and if we didn't
have tomb raider we could at least make
do with the
pitfall harry or any of the other myriad
adventure games
but without resident evil would any
other game series have been able to step
up and deliver the scares the chills and
the creeps as effectively
these movies based on the game franchise
tend to do better
outside the united states and i chalk
that up to horror
being a universal language we can all
speak it and we're all fluent
in peeing our pants when we're
frightened we've just never seen
anything as close to effective as when
it hit gaming consoles
way back in 1996.
mortal kombat gets major points for
being a cultural touchstone
however i'm giving the round to the most
intense gaming series i've been a part
of that's not named tecmo bowl
resident evil it's two to two to one to
the street fighter tried and we got us a
tie
so now it's on me your host raised on
video games
and movies to break the tie between
mortal kombat and resident evil
and for me it comes down to staying
power mortal kombat
is great and the 1995 iteration is my
favorite video game
movie by a sizable margin but after
1997's
truly awful annihilation mk live action
movies took
a long cat nap and didn't awaken until
this year
for contrast we only had to wait like
eight years after bad nipples for
christopher nolan to successfully reboot
the caped crusader
resident evil on the other hand has been
a consistent presence in the box office
since 2002. it's seemingly impervious to
critical barbs
and that's thanks to a fan base that
knows what it wants and feels respected
by the filmmakers that their love of the
game and the storyline they're in
is honored in the language of cinema i'm
giving resident evil the win
here one video game movie that has
success should be lauded as an
achievement
but six video game movies that gross a
combined one and a half
billion dollars at the box office that
friends
is a dynasty and should be remembered as
such
well i hope you remember me mark ellis
or at least long enough to hit me up on
social media at mark ellis live and let
me know
your pick for the greatest worst
freshest
rotten bestest awfulest video game movie
series ever
and i'm gonna go ahead and chalk this
bit up as a flawless victory
seriously i nailed it in one take right
yeah i got that sentence out toasty
you